[Musique]
cachée au fond d'un fjord c'est une île
unique où les rares voisins se font
timides
ne cherchez pas de voiture ici le moyen
de transport et le vtt gaulle toit
pendant des centaines d'années et est
reconnue pour la pêche à la morue
aujourd'hui c'est une terre d'asile pour
ceux qui y vivent
c'est très tranquille ici très paisible
60 bien dans les années 70 l'usiné de
transformation de poisson le poumon de
l'économie a fermé ses portes
la population est depuis passée de 6
cents à 115 personnes
année après année les maisons se vide
il y avait foule ici quand nous étions
jeunes c'était génial
maintenant il n'y a plus d'enfants on ne
les voit plus jouer dehors comme avant
nerveuse nos questions sur google 3com
sur des dizaines d'autres villages de la
province
une menace plane la fermeture
d'autant plus que la province offre des
compensations financières d'un quart de
million de dollars par propriétaire pour
mettre la clé sous la porte du village
ces quinze fois plus que la valeur
moyenne d'une maison ici montant offert
à la condition que les citoyens organise
un référendum et que 90 % des résidents
soient d'accord pour accepter l'offre
la tentation de partir est forte c'est
beaucoup d'argent pour repartir à neuf
mais ici c'est aussi mon chez-moi terre
neuve et labrador est la province la
plus endettée par habitant au pays
une offre qui traduit bien le malaise
économique de la province
couper dans les services et s'en
débarrasser les résidents ici ont déjà
voté deux fois et les deux fois près de
80 % d'entre eux voulaient partir gaulle
toit est déchiré mais voilà qu'arrive
jane pittsfield une ontarienne venu en
vacances 135 fois en dix ans a goal toi
elle n'a pas juste l'air d'une
politicienne elle est élue préfet de la
mrc de pontiac au québec en 2010 est
elle fait des communautés en déclin et
son cheval de bataille
jane s'est donné comme mission de sauver
ce village comment lui dans la vie c'est
de revitaliser les petites communautés
très gratifiant j'ai une voix grave
elle a investi dans une boutique d'art
une salle de spectacle et ce soir ça ce
n est là aussi ressuscités l'ancien
hôtel depuis elle affiche complet quatre
mois par année le conseil municipal est
ravi de voir l'énergie de jane j'adore
ce qu'elle fait j'ai toujours soutenu
les efforts de jane depuis son arrivée
ici je ferai tout en mon pouvoir pour
continuer à soutenir son impact
communautaire positif
mais personne n'est dupe tout le monde
sait que les vies sur le respirateur
artificiel
même si ceux qui restent font tout pour
que la vie continue
bingo pour financer l'équipe de
badminton entraînement des pompiers
volontaires une fois par mois la
population diminue et services aussi et
certains comme john atteints de diabète
devront se rendre à l'évidence quand on
vieillit qu'on a besoin de plus de soins
on n'a pas d'autre choix que de partir
et c'est ce qui se passe
la population vieillit le dernier
médecin de gaulle toit a fini par
déserter
une infirmière passe une fois par mois
pour renverser la vapeur
il faut que de nouvelles familles
viennent s'y installer pour l'instant
shakira 6 ans et le dernier bébé de
lille
l'idée d'un bébé tout neuf pour marc
cela signifierait beaucoup d'espoir un
nouveau né une nouvelle famille
ce serait parfait pour garder le col
ouverte j'aimerais beaucoup voir un
nouveau bébé ici pour attirer des jeunes
il faut des emplois et en ce moment il
n'y a qu'un seul employeur a goal toi
cette ferme d'aquaculture qui se situe
environ à 10 minutes de bateau de gaulle
toi emploie environ un tiers de la
population de l'île
en plus de vouloir générer des emplois
grâce au tourisme
jeanne à une autre solution et elle y
croit plus que tout transformer la
défunte usine en serres hydroponiques
elle veut fournir des légumes frais à
toutes les communautés voisines
en créant ces règles sont louables mais
sont ils suffisants même les derniers
jeunes sont incrédules à vous manquer
le tout on le sent et l'odeur de
l'argent pourrait finir par gagner ceux
qui résistent je ne crois que le
gouvernement réduit la présence sur
l'île un simple fardeau financier
c'est de la corruption pure et simple
je suis une politicienne ailleurs au
canada et je sais que l'on pourrait
créatif et plein de ressources si on le
souhaite
dès qu'une femme doit il faut se battre
et protéger ces communautés plein de
culture et d'histoire
le gouvernement a baissé les bras c'est
marcel à partagent les propos de jane et
son message au gouvernement est claire
vous payer les infrastructures et les
services pour tous les résidents de la
province et nous ici nous sommes
résidant au même titre que les autres
je paye des taxes je mérite les mêmes
services une dizaine de villages ont
accepté la proposition du gouvernement
mais zhang persiste j'espère et je crois
que le vince carter ou pas
celle qui repart chaque fois avec ses
promesses il arrêtera denrier comme toi
la glorieuse comme on l'appelle
pourra-t-elle résister ici et les à
céret radio-canada gaulle toi